On September 20th, witness the origin of the Transformers. Transform and roll out! Yeah! It's the best Transformers ever. This is the greatest day of my life! I can see that. Transformers 1, only theaters September 20th. I'm Jenna Fischer.
9月20日，见证《变形金刚》的起源。出发，变形！耶！这是史上最棒的《变形金刚》。这是我一生中最棒的一天！我看得出来。《变形金刚1》，9月20日仅在影院上映。我是珍娜·费舍尔。
And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office Rewatch podcast just for you. Each week, we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind the scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you.
我是安吉拉·金西。我们曾一起出演《办公室》。我们是最好的朋友。现在我们专门为你制作了终极《办公室》重温播客。每周，我们会解析一集《办公室》，并分享只有身临其境的两个人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。
We're The Office ladies. Hello. Hi there. Well, we have a really fun episode today. I know we say that a lot, but this one is fantastic. This is another one that's just going to put a smile on your face the whole time. It is. Here is what happened. Catherine Tate joined us in the studio for an office lady's interview, and it's terrific. You know, we just picked up right where we left off. It was so fun to
我们是办公室女士。你好。嗨。嗯，我们今天有一集非常有趣的节目。我知道我们经常这么说，但这一集太棒了。这也是一集能让你从头到尾都面带微笑的节目。确实如此。事情是这样的。凯瑟琳·泰特来到我们的录音室接受办公室女士的采访，非常精彩。你知道的，我们就像从前一样无缝衔接。和她一起
reminisce with her and catch up. She is hilarious. You are going to love hearing from her. And you know, we all know her as Nellie on the Office, but she is such an accomplished artist. She is a writer, a director, an actor, a stand-up comedian. She has won several awards for her BBC sketch comedy series, The Catherine Tate Show. But she also played Donna Noble in the Doctor Who series. She's been in so many movies and television shows. And theater.
叙旧和聊天真是太有趣了。她太搞笑了。你一定会喜欢听她的分享。你知道的，我们都知道她在《办公室》里饰演娜莉，但她是一位非常出色的艺术家。她是一位编剧、导演、演员、单口喜剧演员。她凭借BBC素描喜剧系列《凯瑟琳·泰特秀》赢得了多个奖项。但她还在《神秘博士》系列中饰演过唐娜·诺贝尔。她参演过如此多的电影和电视剧。还有戏剧。
Oh, yeah. No. She won the Broadway World UK Award for Best Leading Actress in a Play for Much to Do About Nothing at the Wyndham Theater. And she also got the best leading actress in a play for Much Ado About Nothing at the Wyndham Theatre. And she also got the best supporting actress for the Royal National Theatre production of Alan Ackborn's Season's Greetings. And she does a live comedy show called the Catherine Tate Live Show.
哦，是的。不。她凭借温德姆剧院的《无事生非》获得百老汇世界英国奖最佳戏剧女主角。她还凭借温德姆剧院的《无事生非》获得了最佳戏剧女主角。她还凭借皇家国家剧院制作的阿兰·阿克本的《季节的问候》获得了最佳女配角。她还做过一个名为《凯瑟琳·泰特现场秀》的现场喜剧节目。
There's kind of nothing that this woman cannot do. And she also starred as six different characters in Hard Cell. Yeah. also starred as six different characters in Hard Cell, a Netflix original mockumentary sitcom set in a woman's prison that she co-wrote and co-directed. And you can catch her in Queen of Oz, a sitcom she wrote and starred in as a disgraced member of a fictional British royal family sent to rule Australia. I mean, Katherine, you are so incredibly talented. My gosh. Just really how we snagged her for the office, well, you're going to hear.
这个女人可以说是无所不能。她还在《硬细胞》中饰演了六个不同的角色。是的。还在《硬细胞》中饰演了六个不同的角色，这是一部由Netflix原创的伪纪录片情景喜剧，背景设在一个女子监狱，由她联合编剧和联合导演。你还可以在《澳大利亚女王》中看到她，这是一部由她编剧并主演的情景喜剧，讲述了一个英国王室虚构成员因丑闻而被派去统治澳大利亚的故事。我是说，凯瑟琳，你太有才华了。天哪。说实话，我们是怎么把她请到《办公室》来的，你待会儿就会听到。
But we were so fortunate. And she's also just an all-around fantastic person. Yeah. This might be the hardest I've laughed in an interview because she is so funny and relatable and you know we cover a lot of ground in this interview. It's about her time in the office plus what it was like to move from London to Los Angeles and some big life moments that happened along the way. And of course we ask her the call sheet questions. This truly was one of my favorite interviews and I cannot wait
但我们太幸运了。而且她也是一个全方位非常棒的人。是的。这可能是我在采访中笑得最厉害的一次，因为她太风趣、太接地气了，你知道我们在这次采访中涉及了很多方面。聊到了她在《办公室》的时光，以及从伦敦搬到洛杉矶的感受，还有一路上发生的一些人生大事。当然，我们还问了她花名册的问题。这绝对是我最喜欢的采访之一，我迫不及待地
for y'all to hear it. Same. So let's take a quick break and when we come back it's Catherine Tate. Hello! Hi Catherine! Oh this is this is special. This is special just to be here with you two. I know. In person. I know. It's not a phone in. It's not a phone in. You're right here.
想让大家听到。我也是。那我们先休息一下，回来之后就是凯瑟琳·泰特。你好！嗨，凯瑟琳！哦，这真是，这太特别了。能和你们两个在一起真是太特别了。我知道。面对面。我知道。不是电话连线。不是电话连线。你就坐在我面前。
I'm touching your arm. Yes, you are. I'll touch your arm as well. That's a cool injunction right there. Now you're like, I wish this was a zoom. Oh dear. Yeah, please. I'm going to go and call you from my car.
我正摸着你的胳膊呢。是的，没错。我也摸摸你的胳膊。这真是一个有趣的连接。现在你可能会想，我希望这是一场Zoom会议。哦，天哪。是的，拜托。我要去车里给你打电话。
I know they're going to touch my forearm. Well, let's just jump right in. We're going to ask you the question we ask everyone from the top, which is, how did you get your job on the office? I got my job on the office very, very, like, fortunately and amazingly by Greg Downey, who was going, would you like to be in the office? That's pretty fantastic. That's a pretty rubbish story though. It was, do you know what, it was actually, there is sort of like an origin story to it, because it was supposed to happen quite a long time before it did. Oh. Yeah. I kind of just got this message to say, look, we'd
我知道他们要摸我的前臂了。好了，我们直接切入主题吧。我们要问你一个我们对每个人都会问的问题：你是怎么得到《办公室》这份工作的？我得到《办公室》的工作非常非常幸运和神奇，是由格雷格·丹尼提出的，他当时问，你想不想来《办公室》？这真是太棒了。不过那是一个挺烂的故事。你知道吗，其实它
really like you to be in the office. And I was a huge fan. And I came out to Los Angeles. And I hadn't been to LA very much. I think I'd been once before. And it's a very, you know, it's a pretty, it's not a place that's like any other, especially if you don't come from somewhere like Los Angeles. And anyway, the story was, oh, look, we'd really like you to be on the office. Do you want to come over and have a chat, see the studio and everything? So I go over to Los Angeles, and it's not a scary place, but it's a strange place to me.
有点像是一个起源故事，因为这本应该在发生很久之前就谈妥的。哦。是的。我当时只是收到了一条消息，说，听着，我们
I can't even remember if it was my first time to go to LA or maybe just my second. But it's a crazy place, especially if you come from somewhere like I do, like London Way. We walk places and public transport is an actual thing. I remember staying, I was staying, I mean, I guess it was a bit touristy, but I was staying in Sunset, what's it called? Sunset, yeah, the strip. Yeah, the strip. Yeah. And I was staying at a hotel there. I was meeting someone up at the Chateau Marmont, which is not that, I could see it from where I was staying. And when I got, this is just epitomizes LA to me. And I walked out of the lobby and the doorman said, do you want a taxi, a cab?
我都记不清那是我是不是第一次去洛杉矶，或者可能是第二次。但那是一个疯狂的地方，特别是如果你像我一样来自伦敦这样的地方。我们习惯步行，而且公共交通是实打实存在的。我记得我当时住，我猜可能有点像游客区，我住在日落，叫什么来着？日落，对，日落大道。是的，大道。是的。我当时就住在那里的一家酒店。我要去查特马蒙特酒店见一个人，离那不远，从我住的地方就能看到。当我走到，这简直就是洛杉矶给我的缩影。我走出大厅，门童问，你想叫辆出租车吗？
And I said, well, no, I'm just going up to Chateau Marmont so I can walk. And he said, oh, I wouldn't walk if I were you, man. And I said, why not? And he said, because people will assume something bad has happened to you or that you're a prostitute. If you walk along the road, they will assume that your car has broken down, so you're in trouble. Or they will assume you're tatting for business. I used to walk everywhere.
我说，不用，我只是去查特马蒙特酒店，我可以走着去。他说，哦，如果我是你，我才不走呢，伙计。我说，为什么不呢？他说，因为人们会以为你发生了什么不好的事，或者你是个妓女。如果你沿着这条路走，他们会以为你的车抛锚了，所以你遇到了麻烦。或者他们会以为你在拉客。我以前到处走。
I lived in West Hollywood and my car was crap and I walked everywhere. And I got a phone call from my agent one day and he said, is everything okay? And I said, why? And he goes, I've repeatedly seen you walking down Santa Monica Boulevard. What's happened? What's happened to you? He goes, is everything okay? And I said, I just like to walk. Yeah. It's not, you're toxic now. You're like, you're a strange walkie lady. Yes, I know. This is true. And what's funny to me is that the Sunset Strip is kind of the most walkable area of Los Angeles because there are restaurants
我住在西好莱坞，我的车很破，我到处走路。有一天我接到经纪人的电话，他问，一切都好吗？我说，为什么？他说，我好几次看到你走在圣莫尼卡大道上。发生什么了？你身上发生什么事了？他说，一切都还好吗？我说，我就是喜欢走路。是的。你现在有毒了。你会想，你是个奇怪的爱走路的女士。是的，我知道。这是真的。对我有意思的是，日落大道可以说是洛杉矶最适合步行的区域，因为那里有餐馆
and shops and things within walking distance of one another unlike most of the rest of the city where you so spread out. Where you do have to drive which I still can't but that's someone but that's one of your questions later on. Thank God for Uber, that's all I'm saying. Oh my gosh, what a culture shock though. Oh, it was such a culture shock. Because it's also Los Angeles is not a place that gives up its secrets easily. You've kind of got to be on the inside of it. You've kind of got to know people.
和商店，步行即可到达彼此，不像城市其他大部分地方那样分散。你必须开车，虽然我到现在还不会，但这是你们稍后的问题之一。谢天谢地有优步，我只想说这个。哦天哪，这真是一种文化冲击啊。哦，这真是一种文化冲击。因为洛杉矶也不是一个轻易吐露秘密的地方。你必须融入其中。你必须认识一些人。
Because I mean, there's some places, I don't know if, but it was at the time, this was like over 10 years ago, there are some places where you'd walk past you wouldn't even know that they're restaurants you know that's like you've got to know it's a restaurant and then you've got to sneak in write your name on a secret piece of paper and then in three days they'll call you and say you can come in you know so I just want a sandwich somewhere you know I just want to know where I'm going and know what, you know, I'm very fond of it now because I'm very used to it now.
因为，有些地方，我不知道是不是，但当时是这样的，这大概是十多年前的事了，有些地方你走过去甚至都不知道那是餐馆，你知道的，就像你必须知道那是餐馆，然后你得偷偷溜进去，把你的名字写在一张秘密纸条上，然后在三天后他们会打电话告诉你，你可以进去了，你知道的，所以我只是想在某个地方买个三明治，你知道的，我只是想知道我要去哪里，知道我在，你知道的，我现在对它很有好感，因为我现在很习惯了。
But anyway, so I go to Los Angeles, they invite me over and I remember specifically you were on hiatus. And I guess it might have been you were on hiatus for Thanksgiving. Okay. Or you had a week off and the office was decorated for, I think it was called, was it called Moroccan Christmas? Yes. Right.
不过总之，我去洛杉矶，他们邀请我过去，我特别记得你们当时正在休假。我想可能是你们在感恩节休假。好吧。或者你们有一周假，而《办公室》正在布置，我想那集叫什么来着，叫莫洛依圣诞节吗？是的。对。
Yeah. So the office was all like that. Everyone was, you know, gone. I didn't meet anyone. I sat really bizarrely. He said, you want to come in? And he got me to sit in Michael Scott's chair. And I was there sitting there.
是的。所以办公室就是那个样子的。每个人都，你知道的，都走了。我没有遇到任何人。我非常奇怪地坐在那里。他说，你想进来吗？他让我坐在迈克尔·斯科特的椅子上。我就坐在那里。
Oh my gosh. And I was like, oh my God, and I took this little photo. I was like, I couldn't believe it because I didn't know anything about what he had planned. And we were talking about it and he said, well, look, this is my idea. I've got an idea for you to come in. And he said, it won't happen yet because I've got a show that I'm going to want to start up and running and I think it was Parks and Rec. Right.
哦，天哪。我当时想，哦天哪，我还拍了这张小照片。我简直不敢相信，因为我对他计划的事情一无所知。我们正在谈论这个，他说，好吧，听着，这是我的想法。我有一个让你加入的想法。并且他说，现在还不会发生，因为我有一个想要启动并运行的节目，我想那是《公园与游憩》。对。
Wow. Yeah. But he said to me, this is my idea. He said, you know the character of Angela? It was around about the time that Angela and Andy are getting together. Yeah. At the time, his idea, his nucleus of an idea at the time was for a character. Now, whether or not it develops
哇。是的。但他对我说，这就是我的想法。他说，你知道安吉拉这个角色吗？那是安吉拉和安迪快要走到一起的时候。是的。当时，他的想法，他当时的核心想法是针对一个角色。现在，无论它是否发展
into Nellie, I don't know. I don't know whether that happens. He said, but I would like you to come in and disrupt their relationship. Oh, we would have had a love triangle. I know. Wow. Yeah. I'm certain that's what he kind of had in mind. Anyway, that was a good few years before I joined. And then I guess Parks and Rec really took off. And then it just sort of kind of went quiet.
成娜莉，我都不知道。我不知道那是不是会发生。他说，但我希望你进来打乱他们的关系。哦，我们本来会有一个三角恋。我知道。哇。是的。我确信这就是他心里想的。总之，那是几年后我才加入的。然后我想《公园与游憩》真的火了。然后事情就静悄悄了。
And then I just didn't think anything of it anymore. You know, I was just like, oh, I'll hold onto it, but you don't want to keep chasing. And then honestly, and then it was a good couple of years later, they then went, definitely, we do want you to come over now. And all I knew was that Steve was leaving and that they were kind of, it was almost like, the way I got
然后我就再也没有多想。你知道的，我当时想，哦，我会把这事放在心里，但你总不能一直追着不放。然后说实话，又过了好几年，他们突然说，真的，我们现在确实想让你来。我只知道史蒂夫要离开，他们正在，这几乎就像是我被
introduced, it was almost like it was an interview on camera. It was an audition on camera. Yeah, the whole search party episode. The whole search party episode, yeah. And then I found out the day after, because I came in and filmed, I flew over, because I remember I was doing a play at the time and they let me off for a couple of days to come out in rehearsal, come over and film those scenes. And I remember the last, the second day that I filmed, I came home, my agent rang and said, you want to go out to dinner? And then he said, they've given you the job.
引入的方式，就像是一场镜头前的面试。是一场镜头前的试镜。是的，就是搜寻小分队那一集。整个搜寻小分队那一集，是的。然后我第二天就知道了，因为我来拍了戏，我飞了过去，因为我记得我当时在排练一出戏剧，他们放了我几天假让我去排练，然后飞过来拍那些场景。我记得我拍的倒数第二天，我回家后，我的经纪人打电话说，你想出去吃晚饭吗？然后他说，他们把这份工作给你了。
Oh my gosh. Yeah, they've given you the job. Yeah they've given you the job but I wasn't free. I wasn't free for when you started filming again and I was starting to be free for the last 10 episodes and that's how Nellie came in. Now whether or not had I been free I could have started straight away I don't know. Yeah it was pretty exciting. Wow. It was pretty exciting. Well I want to talk about how Nellie does come in. Yeah. It's in the episode Tallahassee.
哦天哪。是的，他们把工作给你了。是的，他们把工作给你了，但我当时没有空。你们重新开始拍摄的时候我没有空，最后10集我才开始有空，娜莉就是这样出场的。现在，如果当时我有空，我是不是就能直接开始了，我不知道。是的，这挺令人兴奋的。哇。这挺令人兴奋的。好吧，我想聊聊娜莉是怎么登场的。是的。是在《塔拉哈西》那一集。
Yes. And it is one of my favorite speeches that you give. We have a clip. I'm going to play it. Right. Say, so who's leading this thing anyway? So who's leading this thing anyway? Say, I can't wait to meet him. I can't wait to meet him.
是的。这是你发表的演讲中我最喜欢的一段。我们有一个片段。我要播放它。对。说吧，到底是谁在领导这事？说吧，到底是谁在领导这事？说吧，我等不及要见他了。我等不及要见他了。
I can't wait to meet him. Him? You say? Don't think a woman can be a leader? Oh, hey. You poor simple boy. Expected a man, did you? Strong, powerful, huge, whopping penis.
我等不及要见他了。他？你是说？不认为女人能当领导？哦，嘿。你这个可怜的单纯男孩。本以为是个男人，对吧？强壮、有权势、巨大、硕大的阴茎。
Well, sorry to disappoint, but my huge whopping penis is right here and I'm not afraid to use it. Do you know, that is a quote I most get asked right on a photo. No! No! Oh no! Like sometimes, because I do comic cons,
好吧，很抱歉让你们失望了，我硕大的阴茎就在这里，而且我随时准备用它。你知道吗，这是我最常被要求在一张照片上签名的名言。不！不！哦，不！有时候，因为我会去漫展，
because I was in a sci-fi show and I get a lot of office fans. And they come up and they go, could you put a quote? And I go, is it the penis one? And they go, yeah. I, if I'm ever asked to do like a commencement address at a university, I want to lead with that quote and see how many people out there know what I'm doing. Right, right, right, right. It's a big swing, but I'm going to take it.
因为我参演过一部科幻剧，所以我有很多《办公室》的粉丝。他们走过来问，你能写一句名言吗？我就问，是那个关于阴茎的吗？他们说，对。我，如果我曾经被邀请去大学做毕业典礼演讲，我想以那句名言开场，看看台下有多少人知道我在做什么。对，对，对，对。这是一个很大的冒险，但我打算这么做。
Good one. In that episode, you came in and you were front and center. Right, right. Right away. What was that like? Oh, it was pretty nerve wracking. I have to say, because those episodes being filmed, they were kind of split episodes,
好主意。在那一集中，你一出场就成了焦点。对，对。立刻就是。那是什么感觉？哦，那挺让人神经紧张的。我必须这么说，因为那些剧集在拍摄时，它们有点像分裂的剧集，
because half the cast was supposed to be in Tallahassee. Yeah, right. And half the cast were back in the office. So I didn't join with everyone. Or in the bullpen. Or in the bullpen or anywhere where I was familiar with anyone from the office. And I remember my first day I started, no one knew I was starting. Oh gosh.
因为一半的演员应该在塔拉哈西。是的，对。一半的演员回到了办公室。所以我没有和大家一起加入。或者在开放式办公区。或者在开放式办公区或办公室里任何我熟悉的人那里。我记得我第一天上班时，没人知道我要上班。哦天哪。
No one knew I was starting. So I was kind of like, I'm thinking, well, I'm sure they've got me a trailer, but maybe not. I don't know. I don't know how long I'm staying. And I think maybe I found Steve Burgess, but I didn't know who he was. And I was like, hi, I've come to join the office. And he was like, oh, hello, yes. And because I knew Emily, and John was in the cast that went to Hala-hatti, there was a sort of point of contact there, so that was great. But I also remember, you remember the lovely caterers?
没人知道我要上班。所以我当时就在想，好吧，我确信他们给我准备了一辆房车，但也可能没有。我不知道。我不知道我要待多久。我想我可能找到了史蒂夫·伯吉斯，但我不知道他是谁。我就说，嗨，我是来加入《办公室》的。他说，哦，你好，是的。因为我认识艾米丽，而且约翰也在去塔拉哈西的演员阵容中，所以那里算是有个熟人，这太棒了。但我也记得，你们还记得那些可爱的餐饮工作人员吗？
Yes. The lovely caterers, well, they didn't know who I was. And they said to me when I was queuing up, you know, no, this is from the office. And I said, no, no, I'm from the office, I've just joined today. And they goes, you work in the office? And I go, yeah, they assumed I meant production offices and they won't give me any food. They're like, this is cast only. I'm like, yeah, this is for the, no, this is for the program, the office. And I go, no, no, no, I'm in it. And because of course I'm wearing kind of office gear, you know, we all wear office gear, but I was so unfamiliar
是的。那些可爱的餐饮工作人员，嗯，他们不知道我是谁。当我排队时他们对我说，你知道，不，这是给《办公室》剧组的。我说，不，不，我就是《办公室》的，我今天刚加入。他们说，你在办公室工作？我说，是的，他们以为我指的是制作办公室，然后他们不给我任何食物。他们说，这是演员专属的。我说，不，不，这，不，这是给这个节目的，给《办公室》的。我说，不，不，不，我是演员。而且因为我当然穿着某种办公室的行头，你知道的，我们都穿着办公室的行头，但我对他们来说太陌生了。
to them. And for ages, I used to, it took a while for craft services as well. For a while I used to have to get Craig Robinson to go and get me a bagel because they wouldn't let me open the cream cheese. And then when they finally, because it was a while before I was then on the TV, wasn't it? Because you film a few episodes ahead. And then when I started being on the TV, they were so lovely to me. But they generally thought I was, they thought I was a typist trying to chance my arm in for a free meal. I did not realize they were so protective
而且好长一段时间，我，后勤服务部门也花了好一阵子。有一段时间我不得不让克雷格·罗宾逊去帮我拿一个百吉饼，因为他们不让我打开奶油干酪。然后当他们终于，因为那是我上电视前的一段时间，不是吗？因为你要提前拍几集。然后当我开始出现在电视上时，他们对我就太好了。但他们通常以为我是个打字员，想混顿免费饭吃。我没想到他们对
of our food. They were very protective and very, very lovely. And then for a while, I think they kind of used to just go, oh, let her have it. Let her have it. You know what I mean? It's the lady from the production office. She keeps coming down for the oatmeal in the morning. Let her have it. Is that okay, okay, we've left you some. So it was, to your question, Jen, it was nerve wracking because I wasn't just snuck in or introduced. I was just right there. And then she was a brash in your face, very unnuanced kind of character, you know, at the beginning, you know, which is why I do love the way the softer side came in. But yeah, I just had to kind of like go for it, you know, just like hold my breath and go, okay, well, here we go. Take a swing, you know.
我们的食物保护得这么严。他们非常保护，而且非常非常可爱。然后有一段时间，我想他们可能就会说，哦，让她拿吧。让她拿吧。你知道我的意思吗？是制作办公室的那位女士。她每天早上总是下来拿燕麦片。让她拿吧。这样行吗，好吧，我们给你留了一些。所以，回答你的问题，珍娜，这真的很让人紧张，因为我不是悄悄溜进来的，也不是被介绍进来的。我就是直接登场了。而且她一开始是个粗鲁、咄咄逼人、非常缺乏细微差别的角色，你知道的，这也是为什么我很喜欢后来展现的她柔和的一面。但是，是的，我只能硬着头皮上，你知道的，就像屏住呼吸，对自己说，好吧，那就这样吧。豁出去了，你知道的。
Well, I want to say Nellie had a lot of amazing speeches and I have my favorite. It's from the lice episode. Oh, God. When you know, when I was in the makeup truck, I walked into the makeup truck, genuinely thought they'd shaved Meredith's hair. Oh no! Yes, genuinely. It was so good. It was extraordinary.
嗯，我想说娜莉有很多精彩的演讲，我最喜欢的一段。来自虱子那一集。哦，天哪。你知道的，当我在化妆车里时，我走进化妆车，真的以为他们把梅雷迪思的头发剃了。哦，不！是的，真的以为。太棒了。太不可思议了。
I remember pulling her aside going, you know, you didn't have to do that. I mean, we would have stood up for you, for God's sake. You know what I mean? They really did ask her to though. That's the crazy thing. Did they? That was maybe what it was then. Oh, maybe that's what it was. And I'm just going you don't have to do that. You don't have to and then when I walked in I thought she's capitulated
我记得把她拉到一边说，你知道的，你其实没必要这么做。我的意思是，看在上帝的份上，我们本会为你挺身而出的。你知道我的意思吗？不过他们真的要求她这么做了。这就是最疯狂的地方。是吗？那可能就是那么回事了。哦，也许这就是原因所在。我当时就说，你真的没必要这么做。你没必要然后当我走进去时，我以为她妥协了
Okay here we have to watch this one Is that all no, no, that is not all let me tell you what real life is like The men dry up and the nights get lonely The only cause on your machine are from collection agencies about that pair of motorcycle boots you've never even worn. You stalk your old high school boyfriend online, go to his daughter's soccer games and make a scene. You buy a diamond ring for yourself, wear it on your right hand and tell yourself you're all you need. One day, you're alone, tired, at your feet a dying bird. Where did it come from? Why did you kill it?
好了，我们得看这一段。就这些吗？不，不，不止这些。让我告诉你真正的生活是什么样的。男人们日渐枯萎，夜晚变得孤单。你的答录机上仅有的电话是催收公司打来的，催你付那双你从来没穿过的摩托车靴的钱。你在网上搜寻你高中时的老男友，去他女儿的足球比赛现场大闹一场。你给自己买了一只钻戒，戴在右手上，告诉自己你只需要自己。有一天，你孤身一人，疲惫不堪，脚边是一只垂死的鸟。它从哪儿来？你为什么要杀死它？
Is it because in some strange way, it is you? Thank you all for your concern. That is one of the best speeches. Yeah, that was a good one. That was funny. You're so good. But that's the writing as well. I mean, we had gifts, didn't we, every day? We had gifts of writing.
是因为在某种奇怪的way里，它就是你吗？谢谢大家的关心。那是最好的演讲之一。是的，那段很不错。挺逗的。你太棒了。但这也是编剧的功劳。我的意思是，我们每天都有礼物，不是吗？我们收到了编剧的天才之作。
During our re-watch, I would see how you were delivering material, and I thought she must be improvising that or something. It was so well delivered. I'd go to the script and it was scripted for you. The two-hander of what they were giving you and how you were delivering it was just chef's kiss. Thank you, thank you, thank you. Love it. Yes.
在我们重温时，我会看到你是如何演绎台词的，我心想她一定是在即兴发挥什么的。演绎得太好了。我去翻剧本，发现那些台词都是为你写好的。他们给你的双人戏以及你演绎它的方式简直就是主厨的吻。谢谢，谢谢，谢谢。太棒了。是的。
We have just grown to love the character of Nellie so much. And we're seeing these episodes for the first time. I haven't seen them since they aired. What a delicious, like, crazy, wonderful lady. Definitely. Oh gosh, I love it. I mean, I do get a lot in America. It's definitely what people know me for. I mean, I'm bowled over by the fact that it came off NBC,
我们已经深深地爱上了娜莉这个角色。而我们也是第一次看这些剧集。自从它们播出后我就再没看过。多美妙、多疯狂、多精彩的一个女人啊。绝对的。哦天哪，我太喜欢了。我的意思是，我在美国确实很受欢迎。这绝对是人们认识我的原因。我的意思是，我很震惊它竟然能在NBC播出，
like over 10 years ago. But I don't know whether it was COVID, people watch it's like a comfort show, but people watch it on repeat, it seems. The amount of people who go, I just have it in the background, and I love it, and I get to to the end and then I start again. So I'm recognized a lot as Nellie, but I do get this a lot. Oh my God, are you Nellie? I hate your character. I get that a lot at airports, people are like, I hate your character. And I say to them, they go, but you're so good.
大概十多年前了。但我不知道是不是因为疫情，人们把它当成一部治愈剧来看，大家似乎都在反复观看。有那么多的人说，我只是让它在背景里播放，我太喜欢了，等看到最后一集我又从头开始。所以我作为娜莉被很多人认出来，但我确实经常听到这样的话。哦天哪，你是娜莉？我讨厌你的角色。我在机场经常听到这样的话，人们会说，我讨厌你的角色。我对他们说，他们会说，但你演得太好了。
You're so good. You're so good. But I hate her because she is, you know, gosh, she's pretty in your face. Well, speaking of reviewers of The Office have written that the character of Nellie had some of the boldest moves at Dunder Mifflin. And Angela, you made a list. I did make a list. Checking it twice.
你太棒了。你演得太好了。但我讨厌她，因为她，天哪，她太咄咄逼人了。好吧，说到《办公室》的评论家曾写过，娜莉这个角色在邓德米夫林做过一些最大胆的举动。安吉拉，你列了个清单。我确实列了一个。核对两遍。
Here we go. She literally took someone's job because they didn't show up for work. Right. If the chair is open, the job is open. That's right. She kissed Toby to make him stop talking. She told Andy that he was related to Michelle Obama. She pretended to interview Dwight on the radio. Oh, that episode is so great. That's so great. She set up Aaron and Pete and, spoiler alert, she's going to take Ryan's baby.
我们开始吧。她因为别人没来上班就直接抢了别人的工作。没错。如果椅子空着，工作就是空着的。就是这样。她吻了托比让他闭嘴。她告诉安吉拉她和米歇尔·奥巴马有亲戚关系。她假装在电台采访德怀特。哦，那一集太棒了。太棒了。她撮合了艾伦和皮特，而且，剧透一下，她还要抢走瑞恩的孩子。
Right. Did you have a favorite Nellie storyline? I have to say the one thing I thought was gonna sort of like conclude was me and Toby. Did you think you would maybe end up together? I kind of did because we shot a lot of stuff that didn't get used, you know, because we shot stuff that just, you know, you have the luxury of shooting stuff and then of course you've only got, you know, 20 odd minutes in the show. But like for example, this is the other thing that I get a lot which I really chef's kiss to the people who cosplay me as sexy Toby.
没错。你最喜欢娜莉的哪条故事线？我不得不说，我以为会有所结果的一条线是我和托比。你当时觉得你们俩可能会走到一起吗？我有点这么觉得，因为我们拍了很多没被采用的素材，你知道的，因为我们拍了一些素材，你知道的，你拥有拍摄素材的奢侈，但当然，你在一集里只有20多分钟的时长。但比如，这是另一件我经常遇到的事情，我真的要给那些把我Cosplay成性感托比的人一个主厨的吻。
Yes, yes! It's amazing! It's so funny and they do it because what's so funny, I've watched the episode since because my daughter is a huge Office fan, there's so many young people are now huge, huge. I've only now got proper, you know, kudos from being in the office. She was too young when I was doing it. And I've been watching it with her because she genuinely loves it. And I don't know if you remember, they kind of got me like a joke wig. Yeah, it's almost like a Frankenstein.
是的，是的！太惊艳了！太搞笑了，他们这么做是因为，太好笑了，我后来又看了一集，因为我女儿是《办公室》的超级粉丝，现在有那么多年轻人超级超级喜欢。我直到现在才因为出演《办公室》而真正获得了荣誉。我拍的时候她太小了。我一直在陪她看，因为她是真的很喜欢。我不知道你们记不记得，他们给我弄了一个搞笑的假发。是的，有点像弗兰肯斯坦。
Yeah, it was. It was a a joke wig. It was almost like a Frankenstein. It was. It was a Frankenstein wig. And I, because your eyes are always drawn to yourself on screen when you know what was going on in your head at the time. And they didn't pull away enough in time for me. I'm tugging, we're sitting in the office room, you know, in the break, not the break room,
是的，确实是。那是一个搞笑的假发。它几乎就像是一个弗兰肯斯坦。是的。那是一个弗兰肯斯坦的假发。而且我，因为当你知道当时脑子里在想什么时，你的目光总是会被屏幕上的自己吸引。他们没有及时把镜头切开。我扯着，我们坐在办公室里，你知道的，在休息，不是休息室，
the conference room, whatever it is. And I'm tugging at this wig, trying to get it to cover my forehead. But I guess I would have, I did love the Toby storyline because it was such fun working with Paul. And I did, I kind of thought it would be funny for them to, I just have to say the character of Toby, I just think the idea of having someone so inoffensive that someone hates, you know, because Steve's character hated him so much.
会议室，不管那是什么。我在扯那个假发，试图让它遮住我的额头。但我想我当时确实很喜欢托比的故事线，因为和保罗合作太有趣了。而且我确实，我当时觉得让他们在一起会挺搞笑的，我只想说托比这个角色，我只是觉得有这样一个无害到让人讨厌的人这个设定，你知道的，因为史蒂夫的角色太讨厌他了。
There was nothing to hate about it. It's so funny and no explanation. I just hate you. It's very funny but that says a lot about me. Well I have a great photo of us. I need to send it to you. We're on set. Are you Nancy Reagan?
明明没有什么可讨厌的。太搞笑了，而且没有任何解释。我就是讨厌你。这非常搞笑，但这说明了很多关于我的事情。好吧，我有一张我们俩的好照片。我得发给你。我们在片场。你是南希·里根吗？
Yes. And Erin with us the dog? Yes. Yes I've got it too. Oh good good good. You must have sent it to you. We're on set. Are you Nancy Reagan? Yes. And Erin with us the dog? Yes. Yes, I've got it too. Oh, good, good, good. Yes, you must have sent it to me. I have a bunch from that day, I guess. I just got it.
是的。还有带着狗的艾伦吗？是的。是的，我也有。哦，太好了，太好了。你一定发给我过。我们在片场。你是南希·里根吗？是的。还有带着狗的艾伦吗？是的。是的，我也有。哦，太好了，太好了。是的，你一定发给我过。我那天拍了一堆照片，我想。我刚刚收到了。
So funny. And then I have to tell you, speaking of daughters that love the office, when I told my daughter that we were talking to you today, she goes, Mom, what are you doing? I was like, oh, you know, Catherine's coming in. She goes, get out, skeleton man. Oh, yes. She yelled from the hallway. That is another, I would say that's number two in what I'm asked to, to sign. Get out, skeleton man. I mean, my teenager yelled it down the hallway. Has the fact that the office, the American office
太搞笑了。然后我得告诉你，说到喜欢《办公室》的女儿，当我告诉女儿我们今天要采访你时，她说，妈妈，你在干嘛？我当时就想，哦，你知道的，凯瑟琳要来。她说，滚开，骷髅男。哦，是的。她从走廊里大喊。那是另一个，我要说这是我被要求签名的第二大名言。滚开，骷髅男。我是说，我的十几岁的女儿在走廊里大喊大叫。美国版《办公室》是否已经
is now on Netflix in the UK, has that shifted things over there for you in terms of being recognized for Nellie? Because I mean, I was telling Angela, I can't believe we get to interview you today. You're like the Carol Burnett of London, of England. It's like over here, we know you for the office, but over there you're this whole other phenomenon. I have been watching your sketch show before you came on the show. So we were we were fans. Oh, yeah.
现在在英国的网飞（Netflix）上线了，这对你在英国因扮演奈莉而受到认可这件事产生了改变吗？因为我是对安杰拉说的，我简直不敢相信我们今天能采访你。你就像伦敦、英格兰的卡罗尔·伯内特（Carol Burnett）。在这里，我们通过《办公室》认识你，但在那边你完全是另一种现象。在你来节目之前，我一直在看你的素描喜剧秀。所以我们真的是你的粉丝。哦，是的。
Bless you. Yeah. To be honest, I think the office, I was amazed. It wasn't on, it was kind of like on a little cable show before it came on Netflix at home. So not that many people had seen The American Office at home, but suddenly, and it must be Netflix, everyone watches it. But I don't know, I just think the young people caught onto it early. Yeah, the young people caught onto it earlier. But yeah, it definitely has, I definitely get recognized much more now for The Office. Yeah,
谢谢夸奖。是的，说实话，我挺惊讶的。《办公室》在老家上线网飞之前，好像是在某个小有线台播出的。所以其实没多少人在老家看过美版《办公室》。但突然之间——这肯定归功于网飞——所有人都看了。不过我不知道，我只觉得年轻人很早就迷上了它。是的，年轻人迷上它比较早。但确实，现在因为《办公室》，我走在路上被认出来的次数明显多得多了。是的，
it must be Netflix. Yeah. Yeah. Well, I have to ask you about the scene in fundraiser where Nellie doesn't know how to eat a taco. Taco. Oh, God, I remember the spit bucket that I had to have for that. I bet. And they were all so, they were so,
这肯定归功于网飞。是的。是的，我必须问你关于《募捐活动》那一集里，奈莉不知道怎么吃塔可（taco）的那场戏。塔可。天哪，我记得当时我不得不备有一个吐痰桶。我敢说肯定是。而且他们都那么……他们太……
I don't know if they, no, they must have known because they were always so good, weren't they, about art department and props and stuff about because I didn't eat meat and so they made like you know the whatever it was the you know the pretend meat stuff but even so there's only so many tacos you can slide sideways into your mouth and then have to keep tearing it you know but there was a bigger and I remember it because you start by being really respectful of like I'm spitting something out sorry but at the end of it I was literally just like spitting it down in front of Craig, spitting it out in front of him.
我不知道他们是不是——不，他们肯定知道，因为他们一直都那么专业，对吧？比如美术部门和道具等等，因为我不吃肉，所以他们会做那种，你知道的，不管是啥，反正就是假肉。即便如此，你能塞进嘴里、然后还得不断撕咬的塔可也是有限度的，对吧？但还有一个更大的场面，我之所以记得，是因为一开始你真的很尊重剧组，心想：“我要吐出什么东西，对不起啊。”但到了最后，我简直就是直接把它吐在克雷格（Craig）面前，当着他的面吐出来。
Yeah I was wondering how many of those you had. It was a lot. Oh gosh. Yeah. Well had you had you had had a taco right? No I'd never had a taco. For real? Yeah.
是的，我在想你拍了多少个那样的镜头。很多。哦天哪。是的。好吧，你以前吃过塔可吗？没有，我从来没吃过塔可。真的假的？对。
Wait. So when you did this scene, that was your actual first taco? Oh my gosh. I mean, I had heard of them. I knew they didn't have eyes. I'd never eaten a taco. Is it not a thing? It's not as big at home, no.
等等。所以当你拍这场戏的时候，那是你这辈子第一次吃塔可？哦天哪。我的意思是，我听说过这东西。我知道它们长得没有眼睛。但我从来没吃过塔可。这在英国不常见吗？老家那边确实没那么普遍，没有。
It's becoming so now, but at the time, no. No. No. And now Mexican food, my daughter absolutely, it's her favorite food is Mexican food. But we sort of have to wait till we come here to get really, well, better than we get at home anyway. Yes, sure. Actually, they're going to Mexico, so they're going to get some really good tacos. Really good. I can't believe. There was a lot of moments, I guess, on the show where
现在开始变得普遍了，但当时并没有。没有。而现在墨西哥菜——我女儿绝对最爱吃墨西哥菜。但我们基本上得等到来美国这边才能吃到真正正宗的，或者说至少比老家吃到的要好。是的，当然。事实上，他们正要去墨西哥，所以他们能吃到真正的墨西哥卷饼了。非常地道。我真不敢相信。我猜节目里有很多时刻，
it was your real life too. My real life, my real life. Yeah Let's talk about can't drive. Yeah, I know is that crazy. I astound myself sometimes I sometimes wake up and go It's absolutely ridiculous that you can't drive. It's ridiculous Well, I wasn't surprised that you couldn't drive when you were doing the show because you know you were visiting and it's true I lived in London for a period of time and I had no car and it was absolutely not a problem. It wasn't that you couldn't. That's true.
其实也正是你真实生活的写照。我的真实生活，我的真实生活。是的，我们来聊聊不会开车这事。是的，我知道，是不是很疯狂？有时我自己都感到震惊。我有时醒来会想：你不会开车，这简直太荒谬了。太荒谬了。好吧，当你在拍这部剧时，我并不惊讶你不会开车，因为你知道，你当时是在这里做客。确实如此，我在伦敦住过一段时间，当时我没有车，但这完全不是问题。不是说你“不能”学。确实如此。
I couldn't. Well I don't know because then I'd be on the other side and I don't think we want that. So you had to kind of learn how to drive to do our scenes. I know they put the car on. They put it on a rig didn't they? Yes. It was, what episode was that? had to kind of learn how to drive to do our scenes. I know they put the car on- They put it on a rig, didn't they? Yes. What episode was that? That was Andy's Ancestry.
我就是不会。好吧，我不知道，因为如果我会的话，我就得开在路的另一侧了，而我觉得我们都不希望那样。所以为了拍我们的戏，你得学着怎么开车。我知道他们把车放在——他们把它架在一个拖车架上，对吧？是的。那是哪一集？为了拍我们的戏，你得学着怎么开车。我知道他们把车放在——他们把它架在一个拖车架上，对吧？是的。那是哪一集？那是《安迪的祖先》。
Right. They put it on a rig and then they also, I remember they wanted you to eat a salad. That's right. There's a big salad. I've never had a salad before. No. This salad is almost the size of the whole console. It's a big thing.
没错。他们把它架在拖车架上，然后我还记得他们想让你吃沙拉。没错。有一大碗沙拉。我以前从来没吃过沙拉。没有。这碗沙拉几乎和整个中控台一样大。这是一大盆东西。
It's huge. Yes. But then there was a moment where there were a couple of things where, and they didn't even make them in the episode. I don't know why, but they said, you know what, we got this dead end street and we're going to need you to actually drive a little bit. I wish I had footage of it. Catherine, I was legitimately scared.
太巨大了。是的。但后来有一个时刻，有那么几次——甚至都没剪进正片里。我不知道为什么，但他们说：“你知道吗，这条是死胡同，我们需要你真正开一会儿车。”我真希望我有当时的视频记录。凯瑟琳，我当时是真的吓坏了。
I had a hard time performing because I was like, we are going to hit a curb. We're going to hit, I know they've cleared the street. I know it's a dead end, but I did not have full confidence that we weren't going to end up in a lawn. It was so funny to me though. Considering how usually very, very on it they are in terms of insurance. They just suddenly go, yeah, okay, have a go. We might catch something. Yes, that's what it was. You know, we might get lucky. She might do it. It was such method acting for me because they really put me in a car with someone who She might do it. It was such method acting for me because you're truly terrified. They really put me in a car with someone who could not drive. Yeah.
我连演戏都觉得困难，因为我在想：我们绝对要撞马路牙子了。我们要撞上——我知道他们已经清空了街道。我知道这是死胡同，但我绝对没有十足的把握保证我们不会冲进路边的草坪里。不过这对我来说太搞笑了。考虑到他们平时在保险方面通常是多么滴水不漏。他们突然就说：“行吧，好的，你试一下吧。说不定能拍到点什么呢。”没错，就是这样。你知道的，“说不定我们能走运呢。她或许能开好。”这对我来说简直是极致的体验派表演，因为他们真的把我和一个——她或许能开好。这对我来说简直是极致的体验派表演，因为你是真的吓坏了。他们真的把我和一个根本不会开车的人安排在了一辆车里。是的。
That was so fun. Yeah. Well, that's your definition of fun. So wait, does everyone in your family drive but you? Yep. Yep. Absolutely. Well, you don't need to drive.
太有意思了。是的。好吧，这就是你对“有意思”的定义。等等，你家里除了你之外，所有人都会开车吗？对的。对的。千真万确。好吧，其实你根本不需要开车。
My daughter doesn't actually. She's following. She's following my footsteps as I'm following my mom's footsteps. My mom didn't pass her test when she was in her fifties. So I mean, I'm on track. No, but here, well everywhere now it's so much easier. But when I was living here and doing the office, I don't even know this. I was the only person who arrived on set with the driver. I do remember. I do remember. Because at the time, Ubers weren't really
我女儿其实也不会。她正走着——她正走着我的老路，就像我走着我妈妈的老路一样。我妈妈直到五十多岁才通过驾照考试。所以我的意思是，我正在按部就班地进行。不，不过在美国这里——好吧，现在到处都方便多了。但当年我住在这里、拍摄《办公室》的时候，我甚至都不知道这一点：我是唯一一个由专职司机送到了片场的人。我确实记得。我确实记得。因为当时，优步（Uber）其实还没那么……
a thing as much as they sort of like some people knew about them, but you couldn't rely on them. And I had my driver, Sandy, who looked like Father Christmas. And he turned up. And that was the other thing that I kind of felt set me apart a little. It's like, she's turning up with a fancy driver and it's just because I'm too stupid to drive. No. But that's a thing on movies and other shows. That was a thing. You get driven.
普及，虽然有些人知道这东西，但你没法完全依赖它。我有我的司机桑迪（Sandy），他长得就像圣诞老人。他准时出现了。这就是另一件让我觉得自己有点与众不同的事。感觉就像是：她出场居然有专属豪华司机接送，但这其实只是因为我笨得不会开车。不是的。但这是电影和其他剧组里的常态。这确实是常态。会有人专门开车送你。
You get driven and it's because they really don't trust the actor. They do not trust you. They get themselves there. They don't trust you to wake up on time. They send someone to knock on your door and get you in a car on time so that you are on time. It's a whole that you are on time. It's a whole time management thing on sets. But on The Office, we never got that.
有人开车接送你，是因为他们真的不信任演员。他们根本不信任你。他们要确保你能自己到片场。他们不信任你能按时醒来。他们会派人去敲你的门，按时把你弄上车，好让你不会迟到。这是剧组里的一整套时间管理机制。但在《办公室》剧组，我们从没享受过这种待遇。
But it's on all TV here, isn't it? Isn't it a union thing or it's just a culture thing? Or maybe I'm wrong about that. I know another friend of mine, she was on a TV show here, assumed she would be driven but wasn't. No, I've always driven myself. For TV. For TV.
但这在美国所有的电视剧组都是这样，对吧？这难道不是工会规定或者仅仅是一种文化现象吗？或者可能是我搞错了？我认识的另一个朋友，她在这里拍过一部电视剧，她本以为会有人开车接送，但并没有。不，我一直都是自己开车。拍电视剧时。拍电视剧时。
Yeah, you're right. You're right. That's true. But film, it's like, what's the difference? Do they just think TV actors are much more reliable than film actors? It might be. It might be what it is. Film actors, they're crazy movie stars.
是的，你说得对。你说得对。确实如此。但在电影界，情况就变了，有什么区别呢？难道他们觉得电视剧演员比电影演员可靠得多？有可能。这可能就是原因所在。电影演员可都是些疯狂的电影明星。
They're never going to get here. Yeah. But the TV actors, they're the meat and veg of the industry. Also, the TV actors, it's like, we're here for 24 weeks maybe. Right, right. The movie actor, you might be in there for like three days. Exactly. Who knows if he's going to show up.
他们根本没法按时到这儿。是的。但电视剧演员呢，他们是这个行业的中流砥柱。而且，拍电视剧的话，我们可能要在剧组待上24周。没错，没错。至于电影演员，你可能只在那儿待三天左右。完全没错。谁知道他会不会按时出现呢。
Send them a car. But at home, interestingly, film, TV, anything commercial, they don't trust you to do anything. Always a driver. Always a driver. Always sent you a driver or a cab. Never expected. I mean, we are not trusted one bit at home. So kudos to the TV industry here for giving you all such a confidence boost. Get your ass to work.
给他们派辆车吧。但在老家英国，有趣的是，无论是电影、电视还是任何商业片，他们什么都不信任你。永远都会派司机。永远都有司机。总是会给你派司机或出租车。绝不抱期望。我的意思是，我们在老家是一点都不被信任的。所以，向这里的电视行业致敬，因为你们给了所有人这么大的自信心。麻利点，赶紧去上班吧。
Okay. So, Nellie has a lot of interesting romances. Right. It starts off with this weird kind of Dwight Todd Packer thing in Tallahassee. And I found a blooper of the three of you. Oh, really? Yeah. So, Todd Packer is really trying to impress Nellie. Right.
好的。那么，奈莉有很多有趣的浪漫情史。对吧。一切都始于在塔拉哈西（Tallahassee）时，她和德怀特、托德·帕克（Todd Packer）之间那种怪异的三人关系。我找到了你们三个人的搞笑NG花絮。哦，真的吗？是的。所以，托德·帕克当时极力想要给奈莉留下好印象。对吧。
And Dwight, competing for her in his own way, pretends to sleep and snore and does this heavy breathing thing. And the three of you could not get through it. I was going to show you it too. The nightlife in Tallahassee is killer. Yeah. But I got to tell you, since my move to Florida, I really got... Like a narwhal. Their death froze. Oh Jesus. You guys just got so tickled.
而德怀特为了用他自己的方式跟她竞争，便假装睡觉、打鼾，还发出这种沉重的喘息声。然后你们三个人根本没办法把这场戏顺利演完。我本来也打算给你看看的。塔拉哈西的夜生活简直绝了。是的。但我得告诉你，自从我搬到佛罗里达以来，我真的——就像一头独角兽。他们的死相太逗了。哦天哪。你们几个真是笑得前仰后合。
It just delights me. I love watching the bloopers. I love seeing how much fun we had. Was there a scene that was difficult for you to get through that stands out? I really remember and I've got a feeling it was the scene, you know when Andy comes in after being the janitor and he comes in and he talks about David Wallace has told him something and everyone's assuming he's hearing voices and you're going, oh, do you see David Wallace in that?
这实在让我太开心了。我特别喜欢看NG花絮。我喜欢看我们当时拍得有多开心。有没有哪场戏是你觉得特别难演过去、让你印象深刻的？我真的记得——我有一种感觉，就是那场戏，你知道的，就是安迪当过清洁工之后走进来，然后他说大卫·华莱士（David Wallace）跟他说了些什么，所有人都以为他在幻听，而你对他说：“哦，你在那里面看到大卫·华莱士了吗？”
Yeah. I remember that and I remember the person for me who sticks out the most is John being a beast because John would be crying laughing. Yeah. It would be your shot and he would just be doing this. You're doing the shoulders. Yeah. The shoulders and you just gotta carry
是的。我记得那一幕，而且我记得对我来说最搞笑、印象最深的人是约翰，他简直是个怪物，因为约翰会笑得泪流满面。是的。当时明明在拍你的特写镜头，而他就在旁边这样。你在耸着肩膀。是的。耸着肩膀，而你只能硬着头皮继续演下去。
on and then I remember that particular scene crying with laughter about doing that and I think that I probably bury my head somewhere so that you can't see me. Would you ladies be okay if we took a break so I can use the potty and then we'll come right back and maybe talk about Workbus. Yes. We have to talk about Workbus. Deathbus. Yes. All right. One moment. Quick, quick. Okay.
然后我记得拍那场特定戏份时，大家都是笑得眼泪直流，我想我当时大概把头埋在什么地方了，好让你们看不到我。各位女士，如果我们休息一下让我去用个洗手间，然后马上回来，接着聊聊《工作巴士》（Workbus）这一集，大家觉得行吗？可以。我们必须聊聊《工作巴士》。死亡巴士。是的。好的，等一下。快，快。好的。
Should we talk about work bus? Yeah, yeah. Yeah, we're on the bus. And I thankfully managed to get off it. So we all did. But Jenna, that episode, I remember it so distinctly. And that's one of the episodes that I look at. And every time I watch it and I say to my daughter, right there, right there, because
我们该聊聊《工作巴士》吗？对，对。是的，我们在那辆巴士上。谢天谢地，我设法从上面下来了。我们大家其实都下来了。但是詹娜，那一集，我记得太清楚了。那是每当我看到它时都会印象深刻的剧集之一。每次我看这一集，我都会对女儿说：“就在那儿，就在那儿，因为”
they had nothing to cut away to, They kind of had to use the footage. Do you remember of when we just veered off? Yes. And we all slammed into each other. We all slid into each other. And I just have this image of just Ellie careering towards me and her in her wheelchair, roller chair, and me going to the down the steps. I mean, it was absolutely extraordinary.
他们当时没有任何可以切换剪辑的备用镜头，他们基本上只能直接用那个突发状况的素材。你还记得我们车子突然猛烈偏离方向的时候吗？记得。我们所有人都撞到了一起。我们所有人都滑向了彼此。我的脑海里至今还有这样一个画面：艾莉（Ellie）朝我猛冲过来，她坐在那个带轮子的办公椅上，而我则往台阶下方倒去。我的意思是，那场面简直太非同寻常了。
It's crazy. And do you remember when, I mean, we were so dramatic, but we did actually, the window smashed and Creed fell down and kind of pranked. And we didn't know if he was okay. Do you remember that? I do remember that. Oh my God, I do remember.
太疯狂了。你还记得当——我的意思是，我们当时演得很戏剧化，但我们其实真的把窗户撞碎了，克雷格也摔倒了，就好像是在恶作剧一样。我们当时都不知道他有没有事。你还记得吗？我当然记得。哦天哪，我真的记得。
It was Creed, we thought something had happened to Creed, but he was just laying there. He was on the bottom. He had been knocked over and he was covered in glass. And that was a wild, wild episode. Well, I remember after that, we've talked about this, we were all like, that's the craziest thing that's going to happen to us today, is that we went all piled on top of each other.
那是克雷格，我们以为克雷格出事了，但他只是躺在那儿。他倒在最底下了。他被撞倒了，身上沾满了玻璃渣。那真是一个疯狂至极的剧集。好吧，我记得在那之后——我们之前也聊过这个——我们当时所有人都觉得：“这是今天发生在我们身上最疯狂的事了，居然所有人都叠罗汉一样摔在了一起。”
And then Jenna is the one that was like, do you guys smell something funny? And I was in the front and I was like, I don't smell anything. And then she says everyone's like, Oh, classic Jenna. Yeah, yeah, I do. Yeah. With her sinuses and her allergies smell something. But then we were all breathing in carbon monoxide. I remember, I remember standing, because you were kind of like in the middle or towards the back. I was down the front, I was down the front and I do remember you going, come and please guys, please smell, come and smell, come and smell.
然后詹娜突然来了一句：“你们有没有闻到什么奇怪的味道？”而我当时坐在前面，就说：“我什么都没闻到。”接着她说每个人都——哦，典型的詹娜。是的，是的，确实如此。凭着她的鼻窦炎和过敏症闻到了气味。但随后我们所有人都在吸入一氧化碳。我记得，我记得当时站着——因为你当时大概坐在中间或者靠后的位置。我坐在最前面，我坐在最前面，我真的记得你当时说：“大家快来，求求你们，闻一下，快来闻闻，快来闻闻。”
And I remember as people go, anyway, I remember walking down and I remember you going, thank you for validating me. And I'm standing there going, I'll smell it for you, Jenna. And then I'm like, no, actually I can smell something. But I do remember you going, because she was, people were acting as if you were a mad person. Yes, they were. I was one of them.
我记得当大家走过去时——不管怎样，我记得我走过去，然后我记得你说：“谢谢你们证实了我的感觉。”而我当时站在那儿心想：“我帮你闻，詹娜。”然后我又想：“不，其实我也能闻到味道。”但我确实记得你说过这话，因为她当时——大家都表现得好像你是个疯子一样。是的，他们确实如此。我就是其中之一。
I was like, Jenna, it's fine. It's fine. We've all had a crash. What else is going to happen? Of course, that's not dislodged anything, you know, in the whatever it was. The intake. We were so hot. They put the intake for the AC right by the, it was picking up the exhaust and blowing the exhaust in this moving tin can. Oh my goodness. Yeah. That was really crazy. It was really, really crazy. But then we did get to eat pie.
我当时心想：“詹娜，没事的。没事的。我们都经历了一场车祸。还能发生什么事？”当然，那绝对没有震松任何东西，你知道的，不管是哪里的零件。进气口。我们当时热得要命。他们把空调的进气口刚好设在——它把汽车尾气给吸进去了，然后把废气吹进这个正在行驶的铁罐子里。哦天哪。是的。那真的太疯狂了。简直疯狂透顶。不过后来我们确实吃到了派。
And I also have a very vivid memory of my pie being delicious. Yes. And I have a great picture of us. Oh, really? There was, by Laverne's pies and tires. Tires fixed also. Tires fixed also.
而且我也有一个非常生动的记忆，那就是我吃的那个派简直美味极了。是的。而且我们还有一张很棒的照片。哦，真的吗？当时在“拉弗恩的派与轮胎店”（Lavern's Pies and Tires）旁边。顺便也修轮胎。顺便也修轮胎。
There was an old timey truck. And me, you, and Kate did like, and Kate did like, sort of pose like sexy. Were we trying to be sexy land girls or something? Oh, you've got to send me that. I hadn't thought about that in years. It's really funny. I was like, what are we? It's like this old rust iron kind of truck.
那里有一辆老式卡车。我和你，还有凯特——我和你还有凯特摆出了那种——有点性感的姿势。我们当时是在假装自己是性感的土地女劳工（Land Girls）还是什么的？哦，你一定要把那张照片发给我。我好多年都没想起这事了。真的太搞笑了。我当时想：我们这是在干嘛？那是一辆生锈的老式铁皮卡车。
And we're trying to look seductive, leaning up on it. Thinking we'll get our spin-off show. Sexy landlady. Whoop, whoop. You talked earlier about Nellie's softer side, and I have really enjoyed that. I love her friendship with Pam. Yes.
我们斜靠在车身上，试图摆出妩媚诱人的姿势。还以为我们能拍个衍生剧呢。性感女房东。哟吼，哟吼。你刚才提到奈莉温柔的一面，我真的很喜欢这一点。我喜欢她和帕姆之间的友谊。是的。
And I just watched the episode Stare McGeddon, where she kind of serves as Pam's surrogate counselor. And I just loved those scenes. I love her desire to adopt and that whole journey and her tenderness toward Aaron. And also, even how she's so kind to Dwight when he's feeling anxious in that Christmas episode. Can you talk a little bit about her softer side? Yeah, I thought it was a really, you know, it's really nice to have a counterpoint and a balance and also just as an actor to not just come out and be so outrageous, you know, that you can ground the character in a bit of reality and make her someone that she wouldn't be so obnoxious to
我刚刚看了《凝视大战》（Stare McGeddon）那一集，她在剧中有点像是帕姆的代理心理辅导员。我太喜欢那些场景了。我喜欢她想要收养孩子的愿望以及整个心路历程，还有她对艾伦（Aaron）的那份温柔。而且，甚至包括在圣诞节那一集里，当德怀特感到焦虑时，她对他是那么善良。你能聊聊她温柔的一面吗？是的，我觉得这真的很——你知道的，能有一个对立面和平衡点真的很好，而且作为演员，不仅限于表现得极其古怪出格，你知道的，你可以让这个角色根植于现实中一点，让她成为一个——跟她相处起来不会让人觉得那么讨嫌的人，你知道吗？
spend a bit of time with, you know? Yeah, yeah. So it was really nice to, yeah, to do that. I did love it because I used to, you know, sometimes go, really, should she say this? Should she say this? Kind of stuff. They'd be like, yeah, no, yeah, yeah, yeah, you know, she's British or whatever. But it was, yeah, it was such a nice thing
对，对。所以能够去演这样一面，真的是太棒了。我真的很喜欢，因为我过去常常会说：“真的吗？她应该说这话吗？她应该这样吗？”诸如此类的话。而他们会说：“行吧，不，行，行，行，你知道的，她是英国人嘛，诸如此类。”但能把她塑造得丰满立体，并且正如你所说——
to make her fully rounded and also that she, as you say, spoiler alert, that she gets her baby. She gets a baby, anyway, she doesn't get her baby, she gets a baby. She's so happy to get that baby too. I know, I know. Very cute, very lovely and yeah, it's just nice to flex a different muscle, isn't it?
剧透预警——她最终得到了她的宝宝。她得到了一个宝宝，不管怎样，她没能得到她心仪的那个宝宝，但她得到了一个宝宝。她得到那个宝宝的时候也是那么开心。我懂，我懂。非常可爱，非常讨人喜欢，而且，能够展现不同的演技面向，真的是一件很美好的事，不是吗？
When you're in the tapestry of a show like that, and you're used to just turning up and doing one thing, it's really nice to do something else. I loved it when I got to be a different shade of bitch. Right, right, right, right. It just got always the same. Yeah, well now it is. I mean, yeah.
当你参与像这样一部群戏，并且习惯了每次出场只做同一件事时，能够去尝试点别的真的非常棒。当我有机会展现出另一种不同风格的碧池（bitch）时，我可太喜欢了。没错，没错，没错，没错。总是一个样。是的，现在确实是这样。我的意思是，对。
When you think back on your time on The Office, what kind of memory comes up for you the most? I guess it's genuinely having the feeling of, you know, when there's certain times in your life, not even, they're fleeting moments because I think we're, as humans, we're essentially quite selfish and self-involved. But I remember dropping my daughter, sometimes dropping my daughter off to school in America, in Los Angeles, and we were living there, and my mom was living with me, and she'd moved over, and everything was good. And I remember then
当你回想起在《办公室》拍摄的时光时，最常浮现在你脑海里的是什么样记忆？我想，那真有一种纯粹的感觉——你知道的，人生中总有那么一些时刻，甚至都不是，它们只是稍纵即逝的瞬间，因为我认为作为人类，我们本质上都相当自私和自我中心。但我记得有一次送我女儿去上学——有时候在美国洛杉矶送我女儿上学，我们当时住在那里，我妈妈也和我一起住，她搬了过来一切都很好。我记得当时
going, and now I'm going to go and work on the office. And I just remember having a really crystallized moment of gratitude and appreciation. And it's kind of because the show is so loved by people, you can dip into that every day, can't you? Because you go, my God, for a tiny little part and coasting on the coattails of all of you people that were there and set up and everything. And I was so privileged and honored to just come in and coast on the coattails of this fantastic show with this fantastic cast.
心想：“现在我要去《办公室》工作了。”我只记得当时心里涌起了一阵非常清晰强烈的感激和感恩之情。这种感觉部分是因为这部剧深受人们喜爱，所以你每天都能从中汲取力量，对吧？因为你会想：“天哪，我只是扮演了一个极小的角色，却能顺理成章地借着在座各位的光、借着这个早已搭建好的一切飞黄腾达。”能够有机会加入并搭上这部伟大的剧集和这个伟大的演员阵容的顺风车，我感到无比的荣幸和自豪。
But I used to really just go, it was one of those pinch me moments, because it was the only time I've ever watched a show and then been in it. Watched a show, loved it, been obsessed by it and then been in it. And you don't, that kind of doesn't often happen. And so I guess I've brought away this tiny little piece of being part of something so much bigger than my own career. You know what I mean? That I'm a tiny little part in this institution. And so that's a kind of more philosophical thing. I didn't nick anything.
但我过去常常会想，这绝对是那种“掐我一下让我醒醒”的时刻，因为这是我唯一一次先看过一部剧，然后自己竟然成了其中的演员。看过一部剧，爱上它，对它着迷，然后居然参演了它。这种事，这种经历通常是不大可能发生的。所以我想，我带走了这小小的一片段回忆——成为一个远超我个人职业生涯的宏大事物的一部分。你知道我的意思吗？我只是这个伟大传奇里的一个小不点。所以这是一种比较哲学层面的感受。我没有顺走任何东西。
I didn't steal anything. You didn't take anything at the end? No. And I listened to you all and you're going, we took so much stuff and Phyllis didn't get her best bushiest beaver thing. But I didn't take anything. Nothing? I took nothing. But you know what? I found this out about two years ago. They did some job lot,
你没有顺走任何东西吗？没有。我听你们大家说：“我们拿了好多东西，菲利斯甚至没拿到她那个最蓬松的海狸道具。”但我什么都没拿。什么都没拿？我什么都没拿。但你知道吗？大约两年前我发现了这件事。他们当时搞了一场大清仓，
I guess, auctioned stuff from me from the props, right? Yeah. One of the things they were selling was my notebook, I guess. What? Like a notebook from Nellie's desk. Yeah. Notebook. But did it have your real scribbles in it?
我猜吧，就是拍卖剧组的道具之类的东西，对吧？是的。他们拍卖的其中一件物品，好像就是我的笔记本。什么？就像是奈莉桌上的那种笔记本。对。笔记本。但那上面有你真正的涂鸦吗？
Yes. It had my real scribbles in it. And it had on it. And because we went online and looked, I was like, oh my god, you better, I said to my husband, you better buy that. Because can you imagine if I'm going I'm so bored. I don't know what I was going to say. And we looked online. And do you know what one of the things we could zoom in and see was an address. Oh, no, it was an address.
有的。上面有我真正的涂鸦。而且上面还写着——因为我们上网去查看了，当时我惊呼：“天哪，你最好——”我对丈夫说：“你最好把它买下来。”因为你能想象吗？如果我当时在想：“我太无聊了。我不知道自己当时要说什么。”然后我们上网查看。你知道我们放大能看到其中一样东西是什么吗？是一个地址。哦，不，是一个地址。
And you know what it was? It was the place of our first date. Isn't that crazy? Like you had written it. I'd written down, he was going, and this is when we were friends. We were just friends. So I shouldn't say date, but I remember the time, and him going, oh, do you wanna,
你知道那是什么地方吗？那是我们第一次约会的地点。是不是很疯狂？就像是你自己写上去的一样。我写下来了，当时他正在——这是在我们还是朋友的时候。我们当时只是朋友。所以我不该叫它约会，但我记得那个时候，他当时说——
cause he's a writer, and I was like, oh, I'm writing this show, do you wanna do it? And cause he was a dad from the school, and blah, blah, blah. And I remember we met at this Tex-Mex place, and I still didn't eat a taco. I was like, I'll have a salad. But that is so amazing.
因为他是个作家，而我说：“哦，我正在写这个剧本，你要不要一起来？”因为他是学校里某个孩子的爸爸，云云。我记得我们在那家德墨（Tex-Mex）餐厅见了面，而我当时依然没吃塔可。我说：“我吃沙拉就行。”但这真的太神奇了。
That's that moment in time. It had the Tex-Mex address, like 8 PM. Isn't that funny? That is so crazy. Yeah. Your first meeting. No, he wouldn't bid enough for it. Were you surprised when you came on the show how much background work we had to do? How
那就是凝固在时间里的那一刻。上面有德墨餐厅的地址，还有晚上8点之类的字样。是不是很有趣？简直太疯狂了。是的。你们第一次见面。不，他当时出的竞标价不够高。你刚加入剧组时，对于我们必须做那么多的背景戏，有没有感到惊讶？多少
much you had to sit in the background of other people's stuff? Oh my god, yes. Did anyone warn you? No, I did not know. We were there all the time. All the time. But of course, that's what made the show. Because we felt like we lived there and we worked there and we were these people.
有那么多时间你必须坐在其他人的背景里？哦天哪，是的。有人提醒过你吗？没有，我根本不知道。我们一直在那儿。从头到尾都在。但当然，正是这一点造就了这部剧。因为我们感觉自己就住在那里，在那里工作，我们就是这些角色本身。
And actually, it would have been such a different experience if all you did was these isolated scenes. Oh, for sure. It would have just not been the same. But at the time, it was literally... And because a lot of the time I was with Stanley and Phyllis, and I remember her saying, which is true, you know, she always just have her sides in her desk, which is what we go through. And they would get me into these habits of going, just put the sweets in your desk, the candy. And they'd
事实上，如果你拍的全部只是那些孤立的场景，那体验就会完全不同了。哦，那是肯定的。那就绝对不是现在这样了。但在当时，真的是……而且因为我大部分时间都和斯坦利（Stanley）和菲利斯（Phyllis）在一起，我记得她说的话千真万确——你知道的，她总是把台词页放在办公桌里，也就是我们平时翻看剧本的地方。他们会让我养成这样的习惯：“把糖果放在你的办公桌里。”然后他们会——
fill up their thing with coke. I would go over to Phyllis' desk, open her drawer, look at her sides and grab a Tootsie Roll. Right, right, right, right. Oh, so good. Yeah, so good. And I guess, yeah, the other thing I took from the office was what I didn't expect when I left the office was that I have an American life now because I met my husband, not at
用可乐把他们的东西装满。我会走到菲利斯的桌子前，打开她的抽屉，看着她的一侧，然后抓一颗吐茨罗尔糖。对，对，对，对。哦，太棒了。是的，太棒了。我想，是的，我从办公室带走的另一件事是我离开办公室时意料之外的，那就是我现在有了美国生活，因为我遇到了我的丈夫，不是在
the office, but I met my husband because I was over here living. During that time. During that time. And it wasn't until years later we got together, but had I not got that job and lived in that place and my daughter gone to that school, crazy. It's meant to be. No, no.
办公室，而是因为我在这里生活时遇到了我的丈夫。在那段时间里。在那段时间里。直到多年后我们才走到一起，但如果我没有得到那份工作，没有住在那个地方，我的女儿没有去那所学校，太疯狂了。这就是命中注定。不，不。
Meant to be. Well, Angela, do you want to ask your call sheet questions? I do. I love them so much. So here we go. Number one, what was your first entertainment job? Meaning the one I got paid for. Sure.
这就是命中注定。那么，安吉拉，你想问你的采访提纲问题吗？我想。我太喜欢它们了。我们开始吧。第一，你的第一份娱乐行业的工作是什么？指的是我拿到薪水的那份。当然。
Sure. Or just the one I found most entertaining. Your first one. What springs to mind? In entertainment, yeah. I think it would have been on a show before I went to college, and it was a sitcom called Surgical Spirit. And I was someone's girlfriend.
当然。或者只是我发现最有趣的那份。你的第一份。脑子里第一个蹦出来的是什么？在娱乐行业，是的。我想那应该是在我去上大学前的一个节目，是一部叫《外科精神》的情景喜剧。我是某人的女朋友。
Like the mom in it had a son and I was his girlfriend. I think that's the thing I would have got my first paycheck from. And how old were you? Years ago. I would have been like 18. Oh, wow. And did you already know entertainment was what you wanted to do with your life at that point?
就像里面的妈妈有一个儿子，我是他的女朋友。我想那是我会拿到第一张薪水支票的东西。你当时多大？好多年以前。我大概18岁。哦，哇。那时候你已经知道娱乐行业是你一生想做的事了吗？
Yeah, I definitely did because I deferred a year when I got into drama school. So I had a whole year before I knew I was going and this was the summer before. So I like walked into college with like TV credit. Yeah, I've been on the television. Did you even, you barely needed. Right. I mean, what can you tell me? Yeah, I've done on the television. Did you even, and you barely needed. Right, I mean, what can you tell me? I've done your three-year course. All right, next question.
是的，我绝对知道，因为我考进戏剧学校时延期了一年。所以我知道我要去之前有一整年的时间，而这是之前的夏天。所以我仿佛带着电视演员工龄走进了大学。是的，我上过电视。你甚至，你几乎不需要。对。我是说，你能告诉什么？是的，我上过电视。你甚至，你几乎不需要。对，我是说，你能告诉什么？我已经学完了你三年的课程。好吧，下一个问题。
Do you speak any other languages? Yes, I speak French. I speak Spanish. And I speak Italian. Oh, that was wonderful. How did you come to speak so many languages? Well, do you know what it was? I think it comes back to wanting to be an actor because I realized I like to do voices. And I also realized that I was able to pick up languages very quickly because I was able
你会说其他语言吗？会，我会说法语。我会说西班牙语。我还会说意大利语。哦，太棒了。你是怎么学会这么多语言的？你知道是怎么回事吗？我想这还得归结于想成为一名演员，因为我意识到我喜欢模仿声音。我还意识到我能够非常快地掌握语言，因为我能够
to imitate the accent quite quickly. It boosted me because people thought I could speak better than I could, and it boosted me to do better actually than I did. But French, I speak pretty fluently because I studied in France and lived in France. I lived in Spain for a bit because I was a nanny. When I was about 19, I was a nanny in Madrid, and I used to have an Italian boyfriend. Because if you've got one of those languages, they kind of branch off pretty quick, especially
非常快地模仿口音。这给了我很大的自信，因为人们觉得我比实际说得更好，这也促使我实际上做得比我原本能做的更好。但法语我可以说得相当流利，因为我在法国学习并住在法国。我在西班牙住过一段时间，因为我曾是一名保姆。我大约19岁时，在马德里当过保姆，我以前还有一个意大利男朋友。因为如果你掌握了其中一种语言，它们很快就会分支出来，尤其是
Spanish and Italian. If you're learning them, it's kind of easy to see the pieces. But I've just got that brain for sort of languages in a way that I don't have a brain for like maths or indeed driving. I'm not spatially aware, but but yeah I can pick up a language. Alright question number three. What's a place you've been to that you absolutely loved? Oh my goodness there's a lot, there's a lot, there's a lot.
西班牙语和意大利语。如果你在学它们，看清其中的结构其实挺容易的。但我刚好有那种语言头脑，而我没有那种数学或者说驾驶的头脑。我对空间不太敏感，但是，是的，我能学会一门语言。好的，第三个问题。你去过哪个让你绝对爱不释手的地方？哦天哪，有很多，有很多，有很多。
I have to say New Zealand is pretty amazing and I also love, I love Australia. Yeah. I really do love Australia. Sydney is quite fantastic as a city. It's really just beautiful. And it's just sort of got my heart. Bondi Beach has got my heart, which is extraordinary for someone who is pale and ginger
我必须说新西兰非常了不起，而且我也爱，我爱澳大利亚。是的。我真的很爱澳大利亚。悉尼作为一个城市相当棒。真的是太美了。它简直可以说是俘获了我的心。邦迪海滩俘获了我的心，这对于一个皮肤白皙、长着红头发的人来说
and would never go swimming before nine o'clock at night or after five o'clock in the morning. Great times to avoid sharks. Feeding time for the sharks. Bondi Beach is my friend's absolute favorite place on the planet. It's really genuinely got my heart in a way that I never thought it did. I've been to some really fantastic places, but for properly what has your heart, it's Bondi. Did you go there on holiday or work or how did you find it? No, I've been there for work a couple of times because what I didn't realize, I wish someone
而且绝对不会在晚上九点之前或早上五点之后去游泳的人来说真是非同寻常。避开鲨鱼的好时间。鲨鱼的进食时间。邦迪海滩是我朋友在这个星球上绝对最喜欢的地方。它真的实实在在地俘获了我的心，以至于我从未想过会这样。我去过一些非常棒的地方，但论真正俘获你心的，还得是邦迪。你是去那里度假还是工作，或者你是怎么发现它的？不，我去那里工作过几次，因为我没有意识到，我希望有人
had told me, I wish someone had told me years and years ago that I was pretty well known in Australia and New Zealand. I had genuinely no idea. And I went over and toured one of my shows, my comedy shows, and it was like being a rockstar. I had genuinely no idea. And I went over and toured one of my shows, my comedy shows, and it was like being a rock star. I was playing in stadiums. And I just was like, why didn't anyone tell me? Because I genuinely would have moved to Australia years and years ago. So I've been out there a few times and then I've just done a show out in Australia called Queen of Oz. So we went and we lived about six or seven
曾告诉我，我希望有人在多年前就告诉我，我在澳大利亚和新西兰相当出名。我真的完全不知道。我过去巡演过我的一个节目，我的喜剧节目，那种感觉就像是个摇滚巨星。我真的完全不知道。我过去巡演过我的一个节目，我的喜剧节目，那种感觉就像是个摇滚巨星。我在体育场里演出。我当时就想，为什么没有人告诉我？因为我真的很多年前就会搬到澳大利亚去了。所以我去过那里好几次，然后我刚刚在澳大利亚做了一个叫《澳洲女王》的节目。所以我们去了那里，生活了大约六七个月。
months. And so it was just, yeah, it's never been a place where I was thinking, well, because it's so far, you know, it's such an obvious thing to say, but it's a schlep. But then when I got there, I just couldn't believe how much I loved it. In fact, sometimes me and my husband go, because he's from LA and I'm from London, I mean, it's hardly really meeting in the middle, but, you know, I've worked out meeting in the middle. I'm saying it's somewhere like Boston. Yeah. But we go well maybe just you know because LA is his, London is mine, let's have Australia for ourselves, you know, let's let Sydney be ours.
所以这就，是的，它从来都不是一个我会去想的地方，因为太远了，你知道，这么说太显而易见了，但这真是一段折腾人的旅程。但当我到了那里，我简直不敢相信我有多爱它。事实上，有时我和我丈夫会讨论，因为他是洛杉矶人，我是伦敦人，我的意思是，这根本算不上在中间汇合，但是，你知道的，我计算过在中间汇合。我说的是像波士顿这样的地方。是的。但我们会想，也许就，你知道的，因为洛杉矶是他的，伦敦是我的，让我们把澳大利亚留给我们自己，你知道的，让悉尼属于我们。
Oh that's so romantic. It's very romantic. It'll never happen but it's nice. All right let's see next question. What do you like to do on the weekends? I think mainly in my life I'm defined more by what I don't do and what I don't like by what I do. If you asked me what I like, I'd struggle. But if you asked me what I don't like, we'd be here all day.
哦，那太浪漫了。这非常浪漫。这永远不会发生，但感觉很美好。好吧，让我们看看下一个问题。你周末喜欢做什麽？我想在我的生活中，相比于我做什麽，我更倾向于被我不做什麽和我所不喜欢的事物所定义。如果你问我喜欢什麽，我会觉得很难回答。但如果你问我讨厌什麽，我们可以在这里聊上一整天。
So I can tell you what I don't do at the weekend. Yeah, I love it. I cook. I don't like to cook at all. It's not just the weekends I don't like cooking, which baffles me why I've just been offered a cooking show. I think someone heard me on the radio talking about how much I hate to cook and they went, we should actually put this on TV. And it's like, I'm not sure you quite understood my
所以我可以告诉你我周末不做什麽。是的，我喜欢这样。我做饭。我一点也不喜欢做饭。不仅周末我不喜欢做饭，这让我很困惑为什么刚刚有人邀请我去做一个烹饪节目。我想有人在收音机里听到我抱怨自己有多讨厌做饭，然后他们就想，我们应该把这个搬上电视。这就好像，我不确定你是否完全理解了我
feelings about not liking to cook. I would watch you hate cooking. It's not even hating. It's proper like, it's like a primal. It gives me rage. Proper like rage, this idea. And it's what I find doubly awful. It's like with a family and children, you're expected to do it three times a day. And I find that astonishing. And that's why I'm a huge advocate for breakfast cereals. Three times a day.
讨厌做饭的心情。我会看你讨厌做饭。这甚至都不是讨厌。这完全就像是一种原始的本能。它让我抓狂。真正的那种抓狂，这种想法。让我觉得双倍糟糕的是什么呢？就像有了家庭和孩子之后，你被期望一天做三次饭。我觉得这太令人震惊了。这就是为什么我是早餐麦片的坚定拥护者。一天三次。
I mean, because that's what I would eat. I'm not, I digress. Okay. I'm not cooking at the weekend. You're not cooking. I'm not cooking any day, to be honest. Mama don't cook. It's literally, I've got a t-shirt going, Mama don't cook.
我是说，因为那就是我会吃的。我不是，我扯远了。好吧。我周末不做饭。你不做饭。老实说，我哪天都不做饭。妈妈不做饭。简直就是，我有一件T恤上面写着“妈妈不做饭”。
So don't come up with me that I'm hungry. If you want pure rage, ask me for a snack. Right. Oh, it infuriates me. It really doesn't. And in a strange way, because I didn't think I was so un-maternal that I just didn't have the instinct to give people nourishment, but I clearly do. Yeah, no, awful. I hate cooking. I don't want to exercise. You know, I don't want to, I don't mind ambling about but I don't want to do that. I don't want to socialize. So don't ask me to barbecue
所以别跑来跟我说你饿了。如果你想体验纯粹的怒火，那就找我要零食吧。对。哦，这把我气坏了。真的气死我了。从某种奇怪的角度来看，因为我以前不觉得自己那么缺乏母性，只是没有给别人提供营养的本能，但我显然是有的。对，不，太糟糕了。我讨厌做饭。我不想锻炼。你知道，我不想，我不介意随便晃悠，但我不想要那样。我不想社交。所以别让我去搞烧烤
and expect me to throw something on it. That's not happening. I just think I'm actually, I'm quite a natural hermit. I'm a natural loner. I'm definitely not a pack animal. I'm a loner. I'm a lone wolf. And my weekends are, if I had my own way, I would sit in front of Netflix or the TV. I'm sure other subscription services are available and eat stuff that I don't have to cook. That sounds like a great weekend. Yeah. And read astrology things, read astrology books because I love an astrologer. Yeah, I love that.
还指望我随手烤点什么。那是不可能的。我只是觉得我其实，我骨子里是个隐士。我骨子里是个独行侠。我绝对不是群居动物。我是个独行侠。我是个独狼。如果由我做主，我的周末就会坐在Netflix或电视机前。我相信还有其他流媒体服务可用，然后吃那些我不用自己做饭的东西。听起来是个很棒的周末。是的。然后看占星节目，读占星书，因为我很喜欢占星师。是的，我喜欢这个。
What is your sign? Sagittarius. Okay, I'm Pisces. Oh, you are? love an astrologer. Yeah, I love that. What is your sign? Sagittarius. Okay, I'm Pisces. Oh, you are? I'm a Cancer. You are. Why'd you say it that way? Wait, because you're...
你的星座是什么？射手座。好吧，我是双鱼座。哦，你是？喜欢占星师。是的，我喜欢这个。你的星座是什么？射手座。好吧，我是双鱼座。哦，你是？我是巨蟹座。你是。你为什么要那样说？等等，因为你是……
No, I don't feel bad for you. I don't feel bad for your soulful water signs. Yes, that's true. Yes, your soulful water signs. That's why you're so compatible with each other. Oh, yes. Your water signs. I didn't know that. Yeah. Okay, last question. Might be a real roll of the dice now.
不，我才不为你感到难过。我不为你们这些多愁善感的风象水象星座感到难过。是的，没错。是的，你们这些多愁善感的风象水象星座。这就是为什么你们俩这么合得来。哦，是的。你们这些水象星座。我之前不知道。是的。好吧，最后一个问题。现在可能真的是在碰运气了。
Go on. Favorite midnight snack that you don't have to cook. That I don't have to cook. First of all, I'd like to ask who the hell's eating at midnight. That's really bad for you. Snack, genuinely anything I don't have to cook. Yeah. Anything out of a packet, out of a bag.
说吧。不用自己做饭的最爱午夜小吃。不用自己做饭的。首先，我想问到底是谁在半夜吃东西。这对身体非常不好。零食，说实话任何不用我做饭的东西都可以。是的。任何从包装袋里拿出来的东西。
Love a packet. Cereal. I do like cereal. Go to cereal. We would eat cereal at midnight. What's your favorite? Well, we have one at home. I don't know if you have it here.
超爱袋装零食。麦片。我确实喜欢麦片。首选麦片。我们在半夜会吃麦片。你最喜欢哪种？嗯，我们家有一种。我不知道你们这里有没有。
It's called Crunchy Nut Corn Flakes. Crunchy Nut Corn Flakes. Kellogg's Crunchy Nut Corn Flakes. It's basically corn flakes with nuts and honey. Yum. It's called Honey Bunches of Oats. Oh, it is? In the States.
它叫脆果玉米片。脆果玉米片。家乐氏脆果玉米片。它基本上就是加了坚果和蜂蜜的玉米片。真香。它叫蜂蜜燕麦脆。哦，是吗？在美国。
Of oats? There's no oats in it though. Oh. Trick check. I don't know. Come on. Maybe it's not the same. No.
叫燕麦脆？但里面根本没有燕麦。哦。小把戏。我不知道。拜托。也许它不一样。不。
It sounded like you described Honey Bunches of Oats. So what's Honey Bunches of Oats? I'm about to go and buy it right now. It's very good. It's my husband's favorite cereal. So it's oats. It has crunchy clusters and like cornflakes that also are crunchy.
听起来你描述的就是蜂蜜燕麦脆。那蜂蜜燕麦脆是什么？我正打算现在就去买一个。它非常好吃。这是我丈夫最喜欢的麦片。所以它是燕麦做的。它有脆脆的坚果碎，还有像玉米片一样同样很脆的东西。
Yeah, no, these are just pure... Can I just say one of the things, my abiding memories of the office was the kitchen where I counted on my first day, 27 different varieties of cereal because obviously that's my code to meal. 27 varieties of cereal you had in that kitchen. Yeah, yeah. Not the on-screen kitchen, the kitchen where we could go and make a snack. 27. I could not believe it.
对，不，这些纯粹是……我能不能说一下，我对办公室挥之不去的记忆之一就是厨房，我在第一天数了数，那里有27种不同品种的麦片，因为很明显那是我的主要口粮。你们那个厨房里竟然有27种不同品种的麦片。对，对。不是屏幕上的那个厨房，是我们去拿零食的那个厨房。27种。我简直不敢相信。
But also like nine milks. There was like soy milk, oat milk, whole milk, 2% skim. There were all the milks as well in the fridge. It was just like heaven to me. I was going to say, imagine how many more you could have counted had they not kicked you out. Oh, imagine before they went, no, come on, she's upstairs. She's upstairs in the production office.
还有像9种牛奶。有豆奶、燕麦奶、全脂奶、2%低脂奶、脱脂奶。冰箱里有各种各样的牛奶。对当时的我来说简直就像天堂一样。我刚想说，想象一下如果他们没有把你赶出去，你还能数出多少种。哦，想象一下在他们说“不，行了，她在楼上。她在楼上的制作办公室”之前。
Get back up to your sex. I'm sure there was about 52. There was a whole other cupboard, but they didn't let you stay in there long enough. I was only counting the first shelf and then they kicked me out. No, so breakfast cereal, it would be breakfast cereal. An American breakfast cereal because you have this, it was a Trader Joe's apple and cinnamon one, and it became my like crack. Like Apple Jacks.
“快回你的座位去。”我敢肯定大概有52种。还有另一个储藏室，但他们没让你在那里待够足够的时间。我当时只数了第一层架子就被他们赶出去了。不，所以早餐麦片，那就是早餐麦片。一种美国早餐麦片，因为你们有这种，那是Trader Joe's（缺德舅）的苹果肉桂味的，它成了我戒不掉的瘾。就像苹果圈（Apple Jacks）。
I don't know, I've never tasted Apple Jacks and I don't know what fruity pebbles are and all that kind of thing. I don't want fruity pebbles. Cheerios. You can't go wrong with Cheerios. Cheerios are very nice. Angela is a spokesperson for Cheerios. I've done a commercial for Cheerios.
我不知道，我从没尝过苹果圈，我也不知道水果乐圈（Fruity Pebbles）是什么以及所有诸如此类的东西。我不想要水果乐圈。谷物圈（Cheerios）。选谷物圈准没错。谷物圈非常好吃。安吉拉是谷物圈的代言人。我拍过谷物圈的广告。
You have? Yes, you would love it. Oh my God. I eat Cheerios all day. I do, genuinely. And I actually love Cheerios. So I was like eating. I was so with such gusto eating,
真的吗？是的，你一定会喜欢的。哦天哪。我整天都在吃谷物圈。我真的这么干。而且我确实很喜欢谷物圈。所以我当时就像在吃。我吃得兴高采烈，
eating, eating. And Zach Woods directed The Spots. No. Yes, and it's me and Phyllis and Leslie. Oh my gosh. And I didn't know that. Yeah. That would be the perfect thing to do.
吃，吃，吃。扎克·伍兹（Zach Woods）导演了这些广告。不会吧。是的，里面有我和菲利斯还有莱斯利。哦天哪。我之前不知道。是的。那将是件完美的事情。
You should, Cheerios people. You should, a cereal campaign. A cereal campaign. Oh, I'm all for cereal. I mean, my dors was raised on it. Yeah. Oh, Catherine, this was so amazing. Oh, thank you so much.
你们应该，谷物圈的人。你们应该，搞一个麦片广告活动。一个麦片广告活动。哦，我举双手双脚赞成麦片。我是说，我女儿就是吃这个长大的。是的。哦，凯瑟琳，这太棒了。哦，非常感谢。
I love you. I love you. I love you. I love you. I love you. I mean, my daughter was raised on it. Oh, Catherine, this was so amazing. Thank you so much. I'm so delighted. Thank you for coming. This was just the best. A pleasure. You're such a joy to be around.
我爱你。我爱你。我爱你。我爱你。我爱你。我是说，我女儿就是吃这个长大的。哦，凯瑟琳，这太棒了。非常感谢你。我太高兴了。谢谢你来。这简直是太棒了。不客气。能和你在一起真是太开心了。
Thank you. It's because we don't see each other that often. I know. You talk to people who see me every day. It's like, oh, God. What's next for you? What are you? And, you know, we didn't even really get to talk about You talk to people who see me every day, it's like, oh god. What's next for you? What are you, and you know, we didn't even really get to talk about how varied your career is. Oh, don't worry.
谢谢。那是因为我们不常见面。我知道。你跟那些每天都见我的人聊天，就会觉得，哦，天哪。你接下来有什么安排？你是？而且，你知道的，我们甚至没有真正聊到你，你跟那些每天都见我的人聊天，就会觉得，哦，天哪。你接下来有什么安排？你是，而且，你知道的，我们甚至没有真正聊到你的职业生涯有多么丰富多彩。哦，别担心。
Oh, stand up and create a show. Thank you. Oh, I do it all. Theater. Theater. I've just done a play and I'm about to do another one actually next year. You are? Yeah, I'm going to do another one actually next year. You are? Yeah, I'm going to do another play.
哦，演话剧、创作节目。谢谢。哦，我都做。戏剧。戏剧。我刚演完一部话剧，其实明年打算再演一部。是吗？对，其实我明年打算再演一部。是吗？对，我打算再演一部话剧。
I like plays because you get your days free. And yeah. Oh, Jenna and Aisha, come see your play. You must. Wouldn't that be a fun road trip? I love it. Is that your favorite? Do you have a favorite?
我喜欢话剧，因为你白天有空。而且，是的。哦，珍娜和爱莎，来看我的话剧吧。你们一定要来。那不是一次很有趣的公路旅行吗？我喜欢。这是你最喜欢的吗？你有最喜欢的吗？
I don't think I do. Do you know what my favorite thing is to do lots of different things, to do lots of different genres because I, you know, listen, we're always grateful for the, do you know, I was listening to the one you did with Phyllis and it was so interesting that you said, a teacher you had said, work begets work, don't turn work down. It's really interesting that thing, isn't it? Yeah. Yeah.
我想我没有。你知道我最喜欢做的是什么吗？是做很多不同的事情，尝试很多不同的流派，因为我，你知道的，听我说，我们总是很感激，你知道的，我听了你和菲利斯的那期节目，你提到的一位老师说过的话非常有意思：工作会带来工作，不要拒绝工作。这真的是一件很有趣的事情，不是吗？对。是的。
It's really interesting. My teacher always would say, say yes. Really say yes. That's very interesting. And I do think that is say yes. Really say yes. Say yes. That's very interesting. I do think that is the mentality of most actors, isn't it? Because even however successful you've been and however fortunate the things that you've managed to do are, I think everyone's got that mentality of being a jobbing actor. Because what we absolutely know there isn't is job security.
真的很有趣。我的老师总是说，要说“好”。一定要说“好”。这非常有趣。我确实认为那是大多数演员的心态，不是吗？因为无论你取得了多大的成功，也无论你设法做过的事情多么幸运，我想每个人都有那种当打工演员的心态。因为我们绝对清楚没有的是什么，那就是工作保障。
No. And I remember when I was at college, they used to say, oh, here's the thing, you're only as good as your last job. I disagree. I think you're only as good as your next job, unfortunately, in this industry. You know what I mean? It's so cutthroat and it's so immediate and stuff's gone and that's it and you missed it. And there's so much stuff that people are consuming. And when people always say, what's your favorite job? And I always go, my next one. That's going to be the one. Yeah.
没有。我记得我在学校的时候，他们总会说，听着，你只有表现得和你的上一份工作一样好才行。我不同意。我认为在这个行业里，不幸的是，你只有表现得和你的下一份工作一样好才行。你知道我的意思吗？竞争太激烈了，太即时了，东西转瞬即逝，就这样，你错过了。而且人们在消耗那么多的东西。当人们总是问，你最喜欢的工作是什么？我总是回答，我的下一份。那将是最棒的。是的。
But my next one because I think forward, you know, and it's lovely to reminisce, but the joy is the journey, I think. Yeah. Journey and cereal. My autobiography. What was my nickname in high school? Oh, thank you so much. Thank you. Thank you.
但会是我的下一份，因为我向前看，你知道的，回忆过去固然美好，但快乐在于旅程，我认为。是的。旅程和麦片。我的自传。我在高中的绰号是什么？哦，非常感谢。谢谢。谢谢。
Thank you. How amazing is Katherine? I mean, I smiled the whole time we were talking with her. The whole time. The whole time. Well, a huge thank you to Katherine Tate for spending her morning with us and also to you all for listening and supporting Office Ladies. We just love you.
谢谢。凯瑟琳太棒了吧？我是说，我们跟她聊天的时候我一直在笑。从头到尾。从头到尾。好了，非常感谢凯瑟琳·泰特抽出她的早晨时间陪我们，同时也非常感谢大家收听和支持“办公室女士”。我们太爱你们了。
We hope you have a good one and we'll see you next week. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fischer and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our audio engineer is Sam Kiefer and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbaco. Odyssey's executive producers are Jenna Weiss-Berman and Leah Reese-Dennis. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. Oh, yeah There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
希望你们过得愉快，我们下周见。感谢收听“办公室女士”。“办公室女士”是Audyssey的一档节目，由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金斯利制作。我们的执行制作人是卡西·杰金斯。我们的音频工程师是萨姆·基弗，我们的副制作人是艾恩斯利·巴巴科。Audyssey的执行制作人是珍娜·韦斯-伯曼和莉亚·里斯-丹尼斯。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿创作的《橡胶树》。哦，耶 本集节目暂无评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可留下评论。